es una de los migrantes venezolanos que
han visto su sueño de llegar a Estados
Unidos roto esta madre soltera abandonó
Venezuela hace unos meses con su hijo
después de trabajar en Colombia logró
ahorrar dinero y siguió su viaje Ana
pasó hombre durmió a la intemperie Y
tuvo que cruzar ríos y bosques solo para
renunciar a su proyecto porque
lamentablemente no cerraron las puertas
en las narices
no voy a seguir nadando contra la
corriente
Ya
mi cuñado Él me dijo Quédate aquí yo me
voy si no me dejan pasar yo te aviso ya
él Hoy me envió me dijo que no no lo
dejaron pasar lo devolvieron yo le dije
yo no voy a seguir exponiendo la vida de
mi hijo porque me devuelvo por por este
decreto que salió de que no van a dejar
pasar a nadie decenas de miles de
venezolanos están ahora bloqueados en
México después de que Estados Unidos
anunciara que no admitirá el ingreso de
los que intentan cruzar el país
ilegalmente a pie esta decisión tuvo por
sorpresa a muchos migrantes que ya
estaban de camino si bien unos
decidieron migrar a otros estados de
América Latina como Ecuador o Panamá
muchos se han quedado sin dinero y piden
ayuda para regresar a casa el gobierno
de Venezuela Sí si no puede Si pudiera
ayudar a la mayoría
con buenos humanos humanitarios regreso
a la patria debería hacerlo porque hubo
mucha gente que vendió sus viviendas sus
vehículos gente que se endeudó México
firmó un acuerdo con Estados Unidos y se
comprometió a recibir a estos migrantes
venezolanos pero muchos denuncian
maltrato y extorsiones por parte de las
autoridades mexicanas según cifras de la
ONU desde 2015 más de 6 millones de
venezolanos han dejado su país sumido en
una profunda crisis política y económica